[Music]
now as failed negotiator john kerry
continues to deliver what is a cruel
and crushing job-killing message to
america
oil gas energy workers kerry wants
everyone to know that despite all the
major economic sacrifices
you have to make to deliver on his green
energy
fantasies and his stupid paris accord
agreement that
china and india they're developing
nations we pay all the money
and we meet all the rigid standards but
not them under no circumstances though
can he give
up his private jet he says he has no
choice
but to fly in his beautiful private jet
to think to iceland
on that issue pollution i understand
that you came here with a private jet
is that an environmental way to travel
if you offset
your carbon it's the only choice for
somebody like me
who is traveling the world to win this
battle
i'm doing it for the world i'm sucking
it up all for the world so according to
john kerry
you american families we the little
people
well you're going to have your lives
destroyed because of biden and caries
and aoc's extreme
extremist climate fantasies and american
oil gas
energy workers you know that have career
jobs that pay
six figures that let them put money away
buy a nice house new
truck whatever car whatever they want
live in nice neighborhoods
you're going to lose all that he is
under no such obligation to give up his
cushy private plane
it's not for uh practical for someone
like me
oh because he's saving the world what
arrogance
what condescension and do are you
totally cut off are you missing the
switch
of what life is like for the people that
do really make the country great
every day work hard pay by the play by
the rules obey the laws pay their taxes
raise their kids and do pretty much
all the hard work and living in the
country couldn't be more obvious you
might lose your job but he gets to keep
his pollution emitting private plane no
matter what
and of course it's not the first time we
call it a learjet liberal in an act of
blatant hypocrisy
yeah that's al gore back in 2007
getting off his gulf stream at seats oh
12 14 people
only two people on the plane at san
francisco airport
at the same time he was making dire
predictions about the
end of the planet then jumping into a
chauffeur-driven limousine
here for reaction this could be
priceless louisiana senator
john kennedy sir welcome back it's been
a while senator your take
well um
sean i i try to see grace everywhere i
can
so while i'm going to say this firmly i
want to
say it gently i think the american
people are
so tired so tired
of being lectured by the managerial
elite
the entrance politicians the media the
academics
the uh the corporate phonies
the tuna tartare crowd
who live in the expensive condos with
the high ceilings and the important art
on the wall
who think they're better than the
american people
who think they're smarter and more
virtuous than the american people
and who think they are special and that
the rules don't apply to them
i remember the late marilyn monroe
said one time she said if you're gonna
be two-faced
at least make sure one of them is pretty
and uh george burns a famous comedian
years ago used to say
the key to success is sincerity
fake that and you've got it made
i'm not saying that secretary kerry
isn't sincere
and i'm not saying he he doesn't care
about the environment i think he does
but you got to walk the walk man
um respect has to be earned
it's not a participation trophy
uh when when the secretary says look i'm
a busy important guy he is
so the rules don't apply to me
you don't earn respect that way if i
were the secretary i would respectfully
suggest him that he parked the private
plane
why don't we ground all of the private
jets
that we the people pay for all of these
cabinet secretaries now you
know this little truth i don't think
most people do know we've got
whole fleets of private jets don't we
senator that we the taxpayer pay for the
people of louisiana pay for
you're talking about walking the walk or
if they're going to ram this climate
change nonsense a new green deal down
our throat
why don't we ground the whole fleet
maybe we can sell them off or maybe
you know if we don't want to sell them
someone else will use them maybe we can
just oh
recycle the parts well i think there are
a lot of private planes in the various
agencies
um i can tell you i for
for the reason that we just talked about
when i fly back and forth to my
home to my state i always fly commercial
and uh and i always ride in coach
for that reason because people see you
and and judge you by your actions i
don't
mean to wax too philosophical here but
the famous
existential philosopher sart used to say
to be is to act
that all we are is the sum of our
actions
and what you do is what you believe and
everything else is just conversation
so you do sean have to lead by example
and uh i don't buy the premise though
senator
i'm not believing we actually have a net
reduction in co2
uh without the paris accords
um i see china's uh
emitting more more of these gases than
anybody same with india
and we're bearing the brunt and the
burden of the entire world
i'm not buying that well
here's the the irony of all of this the
three
largest emitters in the world of
of co2 are china number one
uh the united states number two
and uh india number three
and only one of those three countries
has actually reduced over the past
decade it's greenhouse emissions and
that's the united states of america
i think i think most americans believe
in an
all of the above energy policy
oil gas wind solar nuclear
hydrogen geothermal but they're also
commonsensical enough sean to know
that we can't run the greatest economy
in all of human history without oil and
gas
and i think that president biden in that
respect is living in la
la land with all i think i agree i think
struggling cognitively weak and frail
too which apparently annoys the hell out
of the media
uh senator good to see you thank you
walk the walk john
kerry and the rest of you liberals